i started the process of
trying to sign nipsey when i was at
warner brothers okay he didn't want to
sign
of course was that when there was
conversations about ross trying to bring
in the mmg
absolutely okay so you were a part of
those part of all that i was bringing
him to miami
we were doing sessions and by the way
ross was trying to sign everybody he was
trying to sign
wiz yeah uh ross had a good don french
montana
yeah everybody yeah we really wanted
nipsey and don was like
we wanted to settle the west coast with
them that was like big
that would have been big for us like to
this day like i still wish in my heart
that happened because
everybody what i want everybody
understand like you guys everybody can
still have their own companies and do
their thing like with me there with
dream chasers and
like well i always tell everyone ross is
like one of the only examples of an
artist
who became an executive that did it the
right way because he i feel like he
genuinely wanted every artist
on his label to be bigger than him yeah
and i think that's the problem most of
the time when you have artists sign
another artist
in their heart of hearts is some ego
should involve they really don't want
their artists to be bigger than them
yeah
but ross i feel like was like his heart
was in the right place
yeah and it kind of showed like with the
success of the label
before we get to nipsey like kind of
give me that backstory about
how close the nipsy and dom [ __ ] was
because i always heard
nipsey and dom were very close to going
to mmg i mean you know the talks got
um you know very intense um you know
um deal structures were talked about you
know things like that
um but you know one thing i could say
about nipsey and dom
they were very keeping their brand and
what they were you know
um what they were developing on their
own was very important to them and they
didn't want that to be overshadowed
so i think them just being you know
their own bosses were very important to
them
and it was like you know 100
understandable
when they didn't want to do the mmg
situation you know it was more so
of a you know we just all wanted that
[ __ ] to happen because we just know how
dope that [ __ ] could have been but
you know at the end of the day they made
it this decision to do their own thing
which you know still worked out for them
so
was was whiz ever close to doing the
mm-hmm i don't think whiz was ever close